want to I want to you know shout out to
Mario I'm going to make this very quick
guys need to go watch it they did a
fantastic job with just about everything
I don't know what the critics at
Hollywood are on I think that's mainly
because there are a lot of them probably
ain't like Gamers and they didn't really
pick up a lot of those Easter eggs that
was in it uh but it is what it is they
voted that I'm telling you not to look
at that and just go watch it uh because
we can't scream for these people to stay
true to the to the script and then you
Gamers don't show up
um
[Music]
it's surpasses
these Gamers showed up so you these they
showed up with a game dedicated to
Gamers so you need to go watch that
movie and that's all I'm pretty much
gonna say no